thank you for the introduction
to talk about some lower balance around
the formulas including our resolution
book system
and this is based on a joint work with
and I
actually especially the introductory
part to this will mirror Dimitri's talk
quite a lot but just for the sake of
completeness like we started in the very
beginning
okay so yeah suppose we have some CNF
student formula and we would like to
know if it's possible enough
that this formula is under unsatisfiable
and here proof is something that we can
check by definitely
and efficient proof is a binomial size
group
and here's like an example of the most
like well-known and well studied food
system its resolution
here we start with the original Clauses
of a formula Phi and we can use these
two rules weakening and resolution rule
to derive some new Clauses until we
arrive at an empty course
and it is not hard to check that this
system is sound complete and that the
proven resolution can indeed be checked
in polynomial time of its size
now who there are lots of proof systems
right and here a resolution
and here's rescue kdnf resolution so
like there are some group systems for
which we can prove lower bounds and
there are some proof systems for which
we don't know how to prove level bounds
and there is a notable shortage of like
methods for proving these lever bounds
like say for resolution for no students
ads we have basement interpolation thing
and for SOS PCR and other things we have
the Restriction technique
but we do not have much more apart from
that
and yeah I mentioned random formulas
right so
these are
candidates to be hard for all proof
systems
and again in some systems we do have
lower balance for random cnfs and in
some we don't
say we have another bounce friend and
formulas in SOS and VCR there are some
known in risque but we don't have
anything for ac03
so in bounded up frega the lower bounds
but we have there like for more
structured formulas pigeon Hall
lactating and there's always always some
kind of switching Lemma involved in this
lover bands
and random cnfs we don't even have lower
bounds for like depth 2 free
and rescue is actually a subsystem of
the flu figure so that was kind of aimed
to motivate you that it's actually
reasonable to study random formulas in
Risk
okay
so
here in kgnf resolution we have like
these four rules which kind of mimic
resolution
with the difference that we
do the operations with kdnfs instead of
Clauses so we have this we can enroll
much like in resolution we have these
two rules with and
which help us to assemble and
disassemble terms of bit K and we have
this cut rule which is very much like
crazy
okay so as I mentioned it is a subsystem
of ac03 again
and actually
non-level bounds random formulas invest
K are also based on some kind of
stitching on small restrictions which
Lemma
and also here's another fun fact about
kdf resolution if we would have a nice
enough rubber Bound for KHS slightly
larger than logarithm from that we would
get a lower bounds for okay which would
be just step two frame at this point
okay and
yeah random double CNS
in this family of formulas we have
n variables mclauses
and the most important parameters
parameter for this formula is density
this M over n the density of Clauses
with respect to variables
so there is this density threshold
and below this threshold these formulas
are satisfiable with high probability
and after this threshold they are
unsatisfiable with high probability
and when you continue to like increase
this density more and more uh these
formulas become
easier to refute with density increasing
because like you have just more
constraints
and at some point when you have too many
constraints you'll just have some local
contradictions and these formulas would
be like very easy to refute
so yeah as I mentioned this family is
believed to be hard for any proof system
uh just after this density threshold
like it's conjectured that
just after this density threshold this
formula should be very hard to prove
and the nice thing about this random
formulas is that their underlying graph
is a byprothetic standard
now what is an expander
here on left side you have some closes
on the right side you have n variables
and
the fact that graph is an expander means
this
that any small subset of vertices on the
left should have a lot of Neighbors on
the right
so expanders had these uh like three
important parameters
are the size of the set and left for
which the expansion property works
Delta is left degree
and there is this expansion parameter
with like this Epsilon evolved here
and yeah here's the picture
we also can ask for something stronger
than just huge number of Neighbors on
the right side
we can ask for a huge number of unique
neighbors they are in pink in this
picture and a unique neighbor is a
vertex which have
just one adjacent vertex in the set I on
the left
okay
so yeah underlying graph of random Delta
CNF is a bipartite expect
and what do we know about random doll
cnfs in ktnf resolution
let's just do not disclose density thing
as this D
and they're basically these two lever
bounds by Eric novich and by segerlin
and the first one we have constant
density and K up to square root of Logan
Overlook Logan
and then the second one the density is
uh and to the one of the six
and here Delta depends on K
and K is constant
so what we're able to do is
this
we were able to improve both of these
and the first setup we were able to push
okay up
and in the second setup we were able to
get a
any polynomial density like this this
should be read as for any polynomial
density there exists some Delta such for
any constant k
yeah and here Delta is also independent
okay
for any particular person because isn't
it true that when the oh oh okay the
polynomial has to depend okay
um so it's like density into the K over
2 becomes trivial what
I'm pretty sure it's for any constant
okay but like first you should pick
polynomial uh and then you should pick
Delta
of the point
so this is this is the formulation
result
uh basically what we require is that the
dependency graph of the formula is doing
not boundary expander with the unique
Neighbors
and the Decay is small enough for this
to be true
and in this case we have an exponential
rubber band for the rescue proof
and now I would like to talk about the
technique which I know is kind of an
optimistic for half an hour talk but let
me still try to do that
the difference between the SBI and
electronic result and what is the
Improvement that I don't yeah sure
that's basically it summarizing this
table so like in the first setup uh M
the number of Clauses is constant times
m
and the K is this
is
[Music]
we were able to get slightly it's like
okay
and then the second setup share like
there's polynomial density but for a
small portion also depends okay
here in red is the information
okay
um
now you mean that you
Delta equal 3 is that Obsession no it's
not Delta equal three we want we weren't
able to achieve that
uh Delta about 100 should do
okay
I mentioned that basically
everything that we have so risque is a
restriction that look
and how does this work uh a general
scheme for any kind of restriction to
play is something like this we would
like to apply a restriction
which preserves the structure of a
formula which doesn't refute it right
away
but it should also decrease some
parameters of the proof in a predictable
way
so the reasoning would be okay we
applied the Restriction uh some
parameters of the proof decreased but
the formula is still not refuted it's to
retain some of the complexity
so this parameters are not zero so in
the beginning they will be huge the
proof was huge something like this
so we would like to make restrictions to
expander-based formulas that lead them
hard
and that's actually kind of the oldest
trick in the book
oh the closure thing the expanders can
fix themselves when you apply then you
delete some part of the graph
again here the left part closes the
right variables
and imagine I want to substitute some
variables on the right the sub t
and after that the graph loses its
expanded properties
and it turns out that we can fix that we
can delete some other small part of the
graph such that the rest is expanded
again
and this trick is widely used in proof
complexity to prove some level balance
again in resolution PCR SOS etc etc
but the thing is uh you can do the
squatcher trick in different ways
so the first way to do projecting
let's just say that we delete the set
that violates expansion
so we again we substituted some set of
variables T and then on the left we have
some Clauses which do not have that many
neighbors so we just substitute all
their neighbors to satisfy those courses
and yeah that is basically deleting this
whole blue part
now it turns out that
this closure disclosure part
will not be too deep we don't lose much
in the parameters of our expander we
lose something in the r parameter
and release something in this expansion
diameter
and actually
we cannot
hydrate this we cannot just apply this
trick too many times because we will
lose this expansion here
but actually
now let's do the second type of question
let's say what we delete the maximal set
that violates expansion
and it turns out that because expanders
are so nice to us
um this maximum Circle will still be not
too big
we still have this predictable loss in
the r parameter and the loss in the
expansion parameter but you can repeat
this with the same guarantee for the
expansion parameter
so you like can delete this set T and
its closure and then you can delete
something else and take closure again
and you will not go below this uh to
Epsilon loss
which is pretty nice
I think this is my favorite type of
pleasure but what we do is like this
secret third thing
ah let's say that we want to delete the
maximal sequence of vertices such that
each next vertex in the sequence
violates expansion so
we deleted the set T if we see a Vertex
that lost too many neighbors let's
delete it if after that we can see a
Vertex that lost too many neighbors
delete it and so on and it turns out
that the set that we get in the end
well it's still not too big we still
have these loss in the expansion but now
the set is also uniquely defined
and this type of the closure also have
other nice properties which we will
explore later
okay
so we know how to make restrictions that
the formula hard
and now we want to learn how these
restrictions affect the proof
and here is the important parameter for
kg units
which is a covering number
so suppose we have a kdnf Alliance in
the proof of Arcadian apps right like
this in the slide this is 3D enough
and the covering is just a set of
variables that hits every term just a
hidden set
like here it's X2 X6
and the thing about covering is uh
if you have a minimal size of covering
at least Q
then you would be able to find Q over K
non-intersection terms in your dnf
just by greedily picking the next one
the manual size of carbon last
unless you do this thing
let's just build a decision tree
and in this decision tree let's just ask
every variable from the covering
in the leaves
put our kdnf but under this restriction
under the corresponding restriction on
the path
now as we have asked at least one
variable from each term
in the leaves there are K minus 1D masks
so that's like the way to decrease the
other terms if we have a small covering
now this
leads to this idea this is actually what
both of these rubber bands and random
cnfs use
um and it's making use of this dichotomy
so for every line of the proof either we
have a big covering number and then we
would be able to find a lot of
independent terms which are easily
killed by random restriction now this is
um like this is not obvious how to
extract those independent terms because
the fact that the terms do not intersect
that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're independent and our restriction
but we will address this later
just imagine that we're we were able to
extract those independent terms yeah
this is the first feature yeah
yeah and uh otherwise these terms
intersect a lot and we would be able to
replace this line in the group by
decision tree plus a small collection of
canines funding
and then just repeat this K times
and what is left is actually a
resolution
now that's that's the picture that's the
scheme
so again we start from a sequence of
cadence we apply the restriction and
some of them are killed and some of them
are transformed into those trees
and then we apply restriction again
and each one of the K minus one DNX
leaves is either killed or we can
continue to build those trees
do this case steps
in the end you have a sequence of
decision trees
and like this just didn't came from
nowhere this came from a k dnf
resolution proof so these decision trees
can be transformed into a resolution
proof for which we know how to do rubber
band
so that's kind of the general scheme
behind those two lower bounds and random
cnfs that were known
and um yes uh we will address the issue
how to pick those independent terms now
because we know that the restrictions in
expanders have
a very special kind right they need to
be closed
so how do we Peak independent terms well
one could ask for something else except
for the expansion property for example
low right degree of the graph and that
kind of bands the density of the formula
immediately
so if you just try to pick those
independent terms such that they their
neighborhood in the graph does not
intersect then they are independent
but actually
we do not need low right degree to
address this issue because
closure encapsulates very accurately
what part of the graph actually depends
on the term
this disposure and its neighbors
and the closure has small size and it's
independent of the radiographer
so yeah
yeah let us return to this picture
with the pink cucumbers
so we have this dichotomy with the cover
number
and as I mentioned expanders are very
nice to us
so let me just try to say magical word
closure three times and say if we get a
new overbound
and yeah that's it
so instead of just covering number let's
just look at closure covering number and
we will look for closure independent
terms and we will reduce not the size of
churn but the size of version
that's it I've said it three times
okay
so now the dichotomy
is like this
we either have a lot of terms which
closures do not intersect
either
we have a line in the proof and the
closures of terms intersect a lot
so yeah closure independent terms behave
very nicely and the closed restrictions
so indeed if we have a lot of closure
independent terms then
this line in the proof will be very
easily killed by the type of restriction
that we use
otherwise we will be able to just build
a decision tree like before and reduce
the sizes of closures and we know that
closure doesn't have
much bigger size than the term itself so
let's just iterate this okay times
and we're left with a resolution perfume
and this is the modified picture
we start from again sequence of kdn apps
for sure is quite small
reply restriction
we get the sequence of the trees and in
the leaves of this tree
closures of all terms are smaller
apply restriction again we do this CK
steps for some constant C
again we end up with a sequence of
decision trace and we transform and
transform it into resolution growth
which again we know how to develop about
now
this might sound a bit suspicious
because uh closure
depends very heavily on the structure of
the graph
so we can we really do this can we
really just gradually decrease the size
of closure if we applying all the all
the restrictions
uh yeah
yeah we can because the third type of
closure has this nice property uh it's
subgraph preserving
so yeah that's why we had to do the
secret third thing
um okay that's
that's pretty much it and I also have
this slide with a couple of open
problems
um I mean it's always nice to push K Up
In Cadence resolution
and one could also try to prove some
rubber bands for wheat pigeonhole at
least for k equal to
yeah
and that's it thank you very much
[Applause]
any questions
[Music]
oh yeah
um
I think that's actually a question which
kind of requires a very long answer why
why the parameters are like this but
I think
maybe something
kind of related to your question is um
the fact that
the sequence of a planning restrictions
it's not actually a sequence it's one
restriction so there's like
uh in the original ideas there's like
some kind of section member right here
and here we would use some other measure
but it's still it's not it's not like a
sequence of a solution
I guess if we had a property like in the
second type of posture where we could
iterate this a lot of times I think we
would be able to get a better case
questions with what you think the
barriers of this Beyond square root of
I have no idea actually
yeah that's that's pretty much the
answer to your question
was why why if you could do a little bit
of a Morgan you could get dips too yeah
sure uh suppose you have um like a proof
which has larger K right so let's just
hit the restriction and all the terms
that are greater than
starting with they they get killed and
if we kill all the terms with 8K I just
left with
uh I'm not sure what range of parameters
is here but I guess we could go from
exponential size proof for case like to
worship invocation too
yeah yeah
any other questions
so you mentioned the Wikipedia principle
for arrest tool is there any connection
yes
uh yes
yes a little bit like with the
Restriction thing the thing is that it
seems like this problem would require
some entirely different technique it's
like
uh
we do not know how to prove something
that is like entirely restriction based
or
just foreign
[Music]
thank you